hey guys I'm out of the country at the
moment but we didn't want to leave you
hanging with no clips so here's just
some general Insanity of the day and in
that regard on the issue of gun violence
then there are a number of specific
things that have to happen in terms of
to your question what our Administration
has done under President Joe Biden we
have passed smart gun safety legislation
for the first time in 30 years that
moves the ball forward
but
we've got more to do we have more to do
we should have a national ban on assault
weapons these are designed
these are weapons of war
they're weapons of war that have no
place in the streets of a civil society
we should have red flag laws we should
have background checks why should we
have background checks well because you
might want to know
if someone has been found to be a danger
to themselves or others before you let
them buy a gun
it's just reasonable and we have to and
we cannot be seduced into into
perpetuating this false choice that
suggests that you're either in favor of
the Second Amendment or you want
reasonable gun safety laws
it's a false choice I support the Second
Amendment I also want to see a assault
weapons ban I also want to see Universal
background checks I want to see red flag
flag laws I want to see that our babies
are not sitting in a classroom where
they should be able to learn how to read
and write and explore their ideas about
what the future of the country can hold
but instead they're sitting there
also being taught how to hide in a
closet and be quiet if there's an active
shooter in their classroom
that's what's happening
I grew up in California where you know
I'm going to date myself but when I grew
up you know the only thing we had to
learn was you know duck and under a
table if there's an earthquake right
now our children are literally afraid I
have talked to kids who say
I like this class and I like this but I
don't like going to fifth period why
don't you like going to fifth period
because in that classroom there's no
closet
so there is so much about this issue
that is about saving lives in on every
level
and we need people to have the courage
to act and that is the one thing that is
lacking in this United States Congress
and in legislatures around the country